il ya des tas de gens qui disent moi je
ferais bien la grève med mais c'est
embêtant parce qu'il faut que j'aille au
boulot je ne dirais pas votre nom parce
que vous exercez une profession qui
finalement est une profession d'un genre
un peu particulier vous tenez à garder
l'anonymat
c'est exact oui c'est ça alors je crois
qu'on peut il faut dire tout de suite
votre votre profession elle est bien les
bizarre je croyais pas que ça existait
finalement vous n'êtes pas très nombreux
et l'exil elle l'exercé vous êtes
je suis manifestants professionnels
alors vous manifestez donc comme quoi ça
consiste en fait à écouter non c'est un
peu un lieu commun de dire ça mais enfin
écoutez simplement pour être
manifestants professionnels
il faut d'abord faire des études je veux
dire que vous manifestez d'abord il faut
me dire où et pourquoi vous êtes
manifestants personnels je crois que
c'est parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
beaucoup de temps beaucoup de 10 des
revendications qui font qu'ils
voudraient prothèse houllier et qui
finalement ont pas le temps de le faire
parce qu'ils travaillent alors c'est ça
c'est ça c'est ça s'est passé c'est
notre qu'il ya des tas de gens qui
disent moi je ferais bien la grève med
mais c'est embêtant parce qu'il faut que
j'aille au boulot alors il faut c'est
une chose pour les manifestations
nous devons nous devons nous trouver
dans tous les endroits où il ya groupe
oui voyez dans tout l'est dans toutes
les petites réunions au tout absolument
partout vous faites de la petite réunion
de cinq six personnes jusqu'au grand
meeting à charléty ce chat nous essayons
au maximum de boer est d'accord alors
pour être
manifestants professionnels il faut
faire des études alors que c'est ça
alors il faut passer d'abord par une
école
cette école s'appelle l'idem l'institut
des hautes études de manifestations
alors là je crois que c'est un cycle de
deux années c'est ça vous avez un cycle
de deux années d'études
même pendant la première forcément ce
sont des cours théoriques
naturellement vous avez apprentissage et
confection de la banderole confection de
pancartes
vous avez aussi apprentissage de slogans
de slogans politiques tels que paix en
israël pourrait hausser les salaires ou
encore cherbourg avec nous les vedettes
ne passeront pas c'est à vous avez aussi
par la lime ma tête est malade
exactement tout
toutes ces choses qu'on est on se doit
de connaître au cours d'une
manifestation
je vois que vous dans l'équipe ça c'est
uniquement la théorie chasser la théorie
la théorie comment faire les banderoles
comment tenir
c'est ça le fanion l'euphonium et
uniquement alors par des dessins et par
des notes que vous prenez la deuxième
année c'est les travaux pratiques
c'est ça la deuxième année chez
carrément la pratique alors vous avez
formation de cortèges des formations de
cortège vous avez des stages les stages
dont les formations politiques de gauche
et de droite ne laisse pas et vous avez
lancement du pavé vous avez vu
j'imagine que vous avez également
protection contre la matraque
je vous m'avez couper la parole je sais
exactement ce que les médias nous
avaient à ce que vous avez utilisation
du couvercle de poubelle
surtout surtout la poubelle et vous
savez aussi fort comment dire
apprentissage de confection de cocktails
molotov à huy que c'est intéressant je
tresse importe je suppose que le port du
lot port du casque est obligatoire
il est obligatoire pour les jeunes gens
qui pour les parents qui voudraient que
leurs enfants deviennent manifestants
professionnels étaient au départ pendant
tout l'exercice pratique c'est pas
dangereux dangereux produits tout est
alors est ce que en fin d'année vous
avez
des diplômes avril en fin d'année bien
sûr un sens d'année sa récompense bien
sûr les meilleurs élèves
vous avez par exemple le prix georges
séguy qui récompense le meilleur
manifestants de gauche ou le meilleur
coupures de courant vous avez ensuite le
prix tixier vignancour qui récompense le
meilleur manifestants de et remise du
courant pour la même occasion chaque
tombe
je ne vous le fais pas dire bien sûr
vraiment d'écouter eux
voilà je vous remercie je m'excuse à je
vais être obligée d'arrêter l'interview
parce que là j'ai une manifestation à 8
heures pour la paix en israël et à 9h
pour el fath alors forcément les
dernières questions justes puisque
puisque vous partez
qu'est ce qui se passe parce qu'il peut
y avoir des retards imaginer par exemple
que la manifestation d'israël se termine
bon à 9h15 9h20 seulement alors c'est un
problème parce qu'il ya plus personne à
l'autre et vous tiendra ce moment là on
se fait remplacer on peut se faire en
tête oui c'est ça vous n'êtes pas
titulaire d'une manifestation c'est
interchangeables vous pouvez vous faire
par exemple ce soir en admettant la
première manifestation où il ya des
encombrements vous pouvez pas vous garer
tout ça vous perdez du temps alors
qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous faites là
je téléphone à mon beau-frère les votre
beau frère est également
manifestons positionne non non ils
exercent une profession en 1ère page à
lire il est un peu au courant quand même
du truck series ce groupe à quoi il sait
comment on s'en tient dans ces cas-ci
fait il est flic
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]